your average commute is pretty
rubbish unless you get to drive one of
these in the city of Hyderabad India
you'll find the ultimate Motorhead but
he's not just a
collector sudhakar makes the world's
craziest
[Music]
cars from every fre day objects like a
computer tennis ball or Burger to a
toilet and a Christmas tree he's made
just about anything you can think of
this is the only handmade vaka Museum in
the world uh well I've created about uh
700 different type of uh vehicles at the
age of 14 I started growing up near
local junkyards Saka was always finding
something to build but it wasn't always
SCS his love of V Wheels started with
bicycles and after that I worked on lot
of motorcycles uh vintage cars winage
double decker buses for the
tourism the first vaki car I made is a
shoe shape car and then I made a camera
car but sudhakar did not stop there he
went on to make hundreds of vaky designs
cricket bat shaped car cricket ball
shaped car football basket ball golf
ball Christmas tree shaped car mug
shaped car he's even made a drivable
snooker table as a child I used to tell
him to make something that I'd see
around probably like a Sharna car or a
pencil bike or you know eraser those are
the things that would interest a child
uh I I'm taking the Legacy forward with
the museum not only the designing part I
also assist him uh with the management
we sit together design it we flesh it
out and give it a good structure I help
him with the technical aspect of it as
well now lots of people call him mad um
he believed in it he belied himself and
uh look where the museum is right now he
is in touch with his inner child and he
does whatever makes him truly happy even
sudhakar's office is on
brand it might come as a surprise but
from 9 to 5 sudaka runs his family
printing business making wacky cars is
is not his full-time job my hobby is not
expensive my hobby is quite time
consuming uh at least 4 to 5 hours every
day I'm still working we see that how
big it should be for the wheel placement
then I go to the junkyards and uh how
much power we need every car is a
challenging jump each wacky car his team
creates is totally unique and they're
always designed from scratch so to build
one car can take anywhere from 3 months
to a whole year it's no surprise he has
earned his place in record books with
his most impressive achievement being
the world's largest tricycle and it's
not just sudhakar with the big Ideas it
struck me that we don't have anything
specially designed for women and I said
you know we have to have an entire
series an Indian traditional Bridal car
a handbag and a stiletto all of these
have been uh designed by me so I bring a
little bit of femininity into the entire
Museum when I started the museum with
the small shed I kept on adding the cars
because I don't like to sell them since
then sudhakar has built a pretty big
extension on his shed and his collection
has caught the attention of all the
locals especially on the roads I used to
have Road shows organized by the
government of Andra Pradesh you know and
then we give free rights to the children
you know they love it if you can't get
to Hyderabad it might not be long before
there's a museum on your doorstep so we
have uh a museum coming up in lonavla
which is close to Bombay before moving
Westward we want to tap into Far East
countries like Singapore Malaysia and we
want to expand it to the rest of the
world if they can't come down to India
we'll bring it to them in the beginning
people used to call me mad a cycus guy I
love doing it I enjoy doing it and uh
that is more
important so that excitement still
[Music]
there